WE WILL HAVE PLENTY OF GOLF TALK
FOR YOU TONIGHT AND A GORGEOUS
ON-SITE, SUNSET.
IN THE WHITE HOUSE WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP PLAYED THROUGH
ON THE NORTH LAWN THIS MORNING.
PRESIDENT USE SOME PRETTY
POINTED LANGUAGE TO KEEP UP HIS
ATTACK ON SOME CURRENT AND
FORMER MEMBERS OF THE FBI
FOLLOWING THE RELEASE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT.
THAT WAS PART OF A WIDE-RANGING
OFF-THE-CUFF INTERVIEW HERE ON
FOX THIS MORNING.
GOOD EVENING, KEVIN.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S PENSION FOR
THE UNPREDICTABLE WAS TAKEN TO A
WHOLE NEW LEVEL AS HE ENGAGED
JOURNALISTS IN A PRETTY SPIRITED
CONVERSATION RIGHT HERE ON THE
NORTH LAWN AND THEN QUICKLY MADE
NEWS THAT TRAVELED AROUND THE
GLOBE.
>> President Trump: IF YOU GO
TO THE FBI AND TAKE A POLL OF
THE REAL FBI, NOT THE SCUM ON
TOP.
>> IT WAS AS FREEWHEELING AND
BOMBASTIC AS IT WAS REMARKABLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY HELD AN
IMPROMPTU NEWS CONFERENCE ON THE
NORTH LAWN FOLLOWING A LENGTHY
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH FOX AND
FRIENDS.
WHILE THE CONVERSATION COVERED A
WIDE RANGE OF TOPICS FROM THE
NORTH KOREA TO THE ECONOMY,
MR. TRUMP ZEROED IN ON
YESTERDAY'S RELEASE OF THE
BOMBSHELL INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT ON THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
>> President Trump: I THINK
THE REPORT YESTERDAY MAY BE MORE
IMPORTANTLY THAN ANYTHING, IT
TOTALLY EXONERATES ME.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION, THERE
WAS NO OBSTRUCTION, AND IF YOU
READ THE REPORT YOU WILL SEE
THAT.
EXONERATE THE PRESIDENT DID
CRITICIZE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
JIM COMEY SAYING HE HAD BEEN
INSUBORDINATE DURING THE PROBE
AND DEVIATED FROM
WELL-ESTABLISHED DEPARTMENT
POLICIES.
>> I THINK THAT JAMES COMEY WAS
UNFAIR TO THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
I THINK HE GOES DOWN AS THE
WORST FBI DIRECTOR IN HISTORY.
>> HE ALSO VENTED ABOUT THE
ONE-TIME LEAD INVESTIGATOR OF
BOTH THE CLINTON AND RUSSIA
INQUIRIES, PETER STRZOK.
A DISCREDITED FBI AGENT WHOSE
BEHAVIOR WAS CONCLUDED AS BIASED
AND ANTITHETICAL TO THE CORE
VALUES OF THE FBI AND DOA.
>> President Trump: PETER
STRZOK SHOULD HAVE BEEN FIRED A
LONG TIME AGO.
>> LATER ALMOST IN PASSING THE
PRESIDENT MADE WHAT AMOUNTED TO
A PASSING ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT THE
LARGEST TRADING PARTNER, CHINA.
>> WE ARE PUTTING TARIFFS ON
TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER THINGS.
WE HAVE TO COME UP WE'VE TREATED
UNFAIRLY.
>> THE RETALIATION SAID THE
PRESIDENT FOR UNFAIR TRADE
PRACTICES.
AND DEMOCRATIC CHUCK SCHUMER
CALLED ACTIONS ON THE MONEY AND
CALLING THEM THE RAIL TRADE
ENEMY.
>> WE WILL IMMEDIATELY RESPOND
AND TAKE NECESSARY MEASURES TO
DEFEND OUR LEGITIMATE RANKS AND
INTERESTS.
>> ALSO GETTING THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTENTION TODAY, ALTHOUGH
PERHAPS UNWANTED ATTENTION WAS
HIS EPA ADMINISTRATOR, SCOTT
PRUITT.
THE SUBJECT OF NUMEROUS
INVESTIGATIONS AND CONTROVERSIES
INCLUDING A REPORT IN TODAY'S
"WASHINGTON POST" THAT AN ENERGY
P.R. EXECUTIVE HELPED HIM SCORE
ROSE BOWL TICKETS.
>> AND LOOKING AT SCOTT AND HE
HAS DONE A FANTASTIC JOB AT EPA.
BUT, I'M NOT HAPPY ABOUT CERTAIN
THINGS.
>> THE EMBATTLED EPA CHIEF IS
UNDER FIRE FOR ALLEGEDLY WASTING
TAXPAYER MONEY AND VIOLATING
ETHICS STANDARDS, AS WELL AS
ASKING SOME GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES
TO RUN PERSONAL ERRANDS.